I love you like a love song baby Selena
Gomez is reportedly off the market
[Music]
according to US Weekly the actress is
dating Andrew Drew Taggart from The
Chainsmokers
according to an inside source Selena and
Drew aren't trying to hide their Romance
by sneaking around at members only clubs
the new couple are reportedly having a
lot of fun together so much fun that
Selena can hardly keep her hands off of
Drew can't keep my hands to myself
just last week Drew was on the call her
daddy podcast discussing his new
relationship with Selena but without
naming her we got set up on a date
a year ago and it was the worst date
either of us had ever been on not fun
and then last summer it just kept
running into each other and then the Bad
Day become became like a fun
conversation point and we like hit it
off on like the Fourth of July and then
started hanging out then ish and August
and then started dating I guess like
September
Michael B Jordan may have a new love
interest the actor has been spending
time with British model Amber Jepson
their relationship is in the early
stages but sources tell the sun they've
enjoyed multiple dates together in the
UK
the kids moved in together so it's been
like a really emotional transition over
on The Today Show Jennifer Lopez gushes
on her happiest year it's just been a
phenomenal year like my best year I
think since my kids were born it looks
like life is good for Mrs Affleck
[Music]